[Musique]
aujourd'hui minimes entendent le noir
toujours exact oui toujours
c'est une vieille habitude tu sais quand
je reviens ici ça me donne la même
émotion parce que je ne voudrais jamais
être en retard pour les répétitions
dépend jeter applaudi a pas longtemps
j'ai rendez vous avec notre cher andré
j'étais contente de doigt ou si je suis
toujours tellement contente de vous voir
et vous allez tout temps au t1 s'en
venait pas il voit partout partout
partout pour mieux que longuet au jour
tout ça c'est magnifique a écouté ses
c'est toujours un peu ma maison quand
même bien sûr je vois toi qu'est bientôt
un horaire et insulté moi vous partiez
j'arrive
et puis je passe le témoin le brigadier
brigadier à à d'autres qui arrivent
et voilà six coups oui le monde être
trois pour les comédiens de molière
trois coups pour les comédiens de talent
de bourgogne je suis en retard mais mais
non on essaie 13 à l'heure pour répéter
avec catherine salviat qu'elle chante
moi j'ai dû faire un petit tour dans la
salle parce que je toujours très ému
venir voir cette salle est cependant
quand je répétais autrefois j'avais
toujours peur de voir la porte du fond
s'ouvrir et quelqu'un écoute et le pic
open mais j'allais subrepticement
écouter des répétitions pour m'instruire
autrefois notamment t1 l'annoncent face
à marie travaille beaucoup avec les
joueurs et jacques leriche je veux
répéter oh mais je me souviens
d'ailleurs c'est incroyable il ya vu une
réflexion je sais pas s'il y avait ou
c'est toi qui avais non dit quelque
chose à claude oui oui je dis nous je le
dit écoutez là là vraiment je comprends
pas ce que ça veut dire qu'est ce qu'est
ce que vous en pensez alors il a pris
lille
il incarne et il était très très
dubitatif mdi
binger du savoir et du savoir mais c'est
à vous de me le dire
et toute façon c'est tellement beau
c'était merveilleux
le truc c'est beau plateau
ça me rappelle cher lucien pascal qui
étaient là pendant les répétitions qui
était d'une minutie dans une précision
tout ça si je ne connaissais plus était
le directeur de chaîne
ça n'était du moment et qu'elle trouver
la sortie
quel merveilleux couple vous avez été au
mans l'harmonie entre une protestante et
catholique
c'est beau mais voilà la surprise
là vous dire un petit bonjour
respectives pour le spectacle de
catherine salviat veut pas venir sans
vous saluer et vous dire que j'étais
heureuse de vous voir là ça doit vous
faire dans le défaire j'ai plein
d'émotions ici car j'ai connu dix
administrateurs quand j'étais encore en
activité et certains m'avait beaucoup
impressionné quand j'entre est ici
appelé ou deux pour demander quelque
chose je tremblais comme une feuille je
regardais un peu de temps le voir mais
je dis que ça me fait grand plaisir
merci beaucoup et puis alors vous venez
on secret pour faire la sonnette
catherine salviat là alors je voulais
pas passer sur vous serrez la mère de
l'initiation alors merde merde merde je
dois répéter sur pie à demain à demeure
voix
[Musique]